hi my name's alan i'm a postdoc in
jordan rush lab in oxford university
and today i'm going to talk about a new
model to probe the pathway of central
and centrosome assembly
that we've termed the saps or sussex and
the two particles
so in jordan's lab we work on centrals
and centrosomes
centrioles are these cylindrical shaped
organelles
which are found in most eukaryotic cells
and they form two important structures
the first of these are the cilium this
is when the centroid migrates to the
plasma membrane and forms
protrusions which can either be motile
or non-motile
when non-motile they're often a
signaling center for the cell
the second structure that the central
can form are the centrosomes
which are the major microtubule
organizing centers of the cell
so why is central's interesting to study
well when you have central dysfunction
this can result in malfunctioning
psyllium
which ends up with various pathologies
such as microcephaly primary dwarfism or
various ciliopathies
meanwhile if centrosomes aren't formed
properly this can result in problems
with spindle formation
resulting in cell polarity cell motility
or spindle alignment issues and as a
result
centrosomes are often associated with
multiple cancers
in our lab we're interested in how
centrosomes are formed
now remember centrosome is a centriole
surrounded by
the so-called pericentronal material a
scaffold of proteins
required for the nucleation of
microtubules
over many years both genetic and
biochemical studies have identified the
key components required for both central
assembly
and pcm formation as you can see
there's a very there's only a very few
proteins required
five for central assembly asterisk plk
for
sus6 and a2 and sus4 and even fewer for
pcm assembly
asterisks spot-2 polo and cnn
all of these components are conserved in
most high eukaryotes and especially
between humans and drosophila
in our lab we use the embryo of the
fruit fly drosophila melanogaster as our
model
for uh studying centriole and centrosome
behavior
as you can see from this movie the
centroids and centrosomes in these
embryos
divide uh very quickly and all in
synchrony
this enables um very simple
quantification of the events
uh going on there is however a problem
with studying
centriole and centrosome formation in
drosophila
and that is that
mutation in any of the five core central
assembly factors
results in the formation of no central
whatsoever
therefore it's very hard to tease apart
the interaction
between the proteins of central assembly
and also it doesn't help with studying
the interaction between
central uh the central and the pcm that
assembles around it
so in today's talk i'm going to discuss
how we've developed a model to study
central and centrosome behavior in the
absence of any of these core central
assembly factors
that model is the saps or sus6 and
another two particles
then i'm going to talk about why we
think they're such a good model for the
for these studies
and then give one brief example of how
we've used the saps to probe centrosome
protein behavior in the absence of one
of these key
core central assembly factors
so the origins of the sap project come
from this publication from our lab about
10 years ago
in this paper the authors were mildly
over expressing
various centrosome duplication factors
in unfertilized eggs now it's important
to state here that
females from drosophila will lay
unfertilized eggs
which don't have any centrioles in them
normally
when an egg is fertilized centrol is
introduced by the male sperm
so these unfertilized eggs normally
don't contain any centroids at all
so the authors found that when you
overexpressed anna 2 to moderate levels
the unfertilized eggs didn't contain any
structures
and similarly when sus6 was also
moderately overexpressed
nothing was seen within the egg however
when both
sus6 and ana2 were co-overexpressed at
moderate levels
particles started to appear in the
cytoplasm of these eggs
these were termed the sus6 another
particles or saps this would suggest
that sussex and anna2 can co-assemble
into higher order structures
in this cytoplasm but what's remarkable
about these assemblies
is when we injected them into cycling
wild-type embryos so what i'm showing
you here is a movie
of a wild type embryo expressing a
microtubule marker in red
with this the saps injected in labelled
in green
and what you can see here is that their
saps
uh organized robust asterisk and
microtubules
whose dynamics appear to cycle basically
in synchrony with the
astral microtubules that are being
organized from the endogenous
centrosomes
so this movie clearly showed that sapps
could organize microtubules
but what about other centriole and pcm
components
when these two panels you can see a
comparison between
saps and centrioles staying for various
central
and centrosome markers i hope you can
appreciate that saps can recruit
robust levels of central proteins
sus4 and atlas as well as pcm components
spud 2 and cnn in a similar way to
that as it's seen in centrioles
so we went on to analyze a bit more
precisely how various central components
were being recruited to the saps
and compare them to how they're
recruited to endogenous centrioles
what i'm showing you here in the top
panel is how sas4 is recruited to the
centrioles
and you can see from the quantification
in the graph that sas4 has a slightly
broader slightly broader distribution
compared to the core central marker
when we now compare this to how sas4 is
recruited to saps
and measure the distance from the edge
of the sap wall
and see where sas4 is localized you can
see it has a very similar distribution
to uh how sas4 is recruited into
endogenous centrioles
we then went on to do a similar analysis
for other components here i'm showing
you
atlas being recruited to centrioles and
to saps
and you can see from the quantification
in the graph that atlas recruited to
saps
has very similar distribution to how
acilis is recruited to centrals
this uh demonstrates that actually the
organization of proteins is remarkably
similar
in both saps and centrioles so it seems
that saps able to organize microtubules
and pcm in a very similar fashion to
that scene endogenous centrosomes
so we're interested to see how the pcm
proteins
cnn and spa2 behaved
at saps compared to centrosomes
these two proteins are phosphorylated
when they're
localized to centrosomes whereas in the
cytosol they're not phosphorylated
if we then look at look to see how these
proteins
behave on the saps we can see that
they're both phosphorylated
compared to their proteins similar
proteins
in cytosol so we can say the pcn
proteins on saps have they're very
have very similar post-translational
modifications
compared to endogenous centrosomes the
crystal structure of both
sus6 and parts of hana 2 are already
known
so we're interested to see whether the
interactions between these two proteins
that occur in endogenous centrioles to
form the beautiful
nine-fold radial symmetric cartwheel
structure
are also present in the formation of
saps the first the residues that we
tried
to mutate was that in the head group of
sus6
now sus6 oligomerizes to form the
cartwheel structure
and when certain residues within the
head groups are mutated
this oligomerization can no longer
happen
and as a result the cartwheel doesn't
form and centrioles don't form
when we overexpress this form of sus6 to
moderate levels along with
ana2 at similar moderate levels we saw
that no
saps could form we also mutated
some of the domains in anna 2 in a
similar way
so ana2 has several domains which are
required for
its polygonalization the coil coil
domains
and for its interaction with sus6 the
so-called stand domain
when the stand domain was was mutated
so such that it no longer interacts with
sus6
and in a wild type situation this
prevents the formation
of the cartwheel and therefore central
formation
when we express this form to moderate
levels in
in our sap model system we could see
that saps no longer formed so the stand
domain in anna 2 is essential for sap
formation
in a similar manner the coil coil domain
of
anna 2 is required for its
oligomerization and this oligomerization
is required for its interaction with
sus6 and the formation
of an endogenous carpal structure in
centrioles
when this was expressed moderate levels
in our sap system
saps no longer formed so these
experiments suggest
that slaps are not simply non-specific
aggregates of proteins
but remarkably require the same
protein protein interactions that
are normally occurring in endogenous
centrioles
but clearly saps aren't centrioles
you can see from this graph this is
quantification of the area
of the central compared to a sap and
saps have a
much broader range distribution of their
their size and saps are much larger than
central's and as a result the total
sussex intensity within
saps is much greater than you can see
within
central's however
when we looked by em
at saps we could see no obvious uh
structure
so there was there wasn't this beautiful
ninefold radial symmetric
cartwheel structure that you can see
within endogenous centrioles
but this was our advantage because
they aren't central they can form even
in the absence
of some of the core centriole proteins
so just to recap what i've told you so
far
saps form when sussex and ana2 are
co-overexpressed at moderate levels
this suggests they have a remarkable
property of um
self organization into into
large co assemblies sap formation
requires many of the same protein
protein interactions that are occurring
in endogenous centrioles
and saps recruit central and centrosome
proteins in a similar fashion
to that seen in endogenous centrosomes
in fact sap show many similar behaviors
to centrioles
in their ability to recruit pcm and then
form microtubule asters so i'm just
going to change gear a tiny bit
and talk a bit about the developmental
biology of
flies which lack centrioles
so as i've mentioned already central is
important in forming two structures
within most cells
those are the psyllium and the
centrosome
now when any mutants in the core
central assembly factors is made in
flies
this results obviously in the lack of
centrioles
but as a result these flyers also lack
both the psyllium and centrosome however
remarkably
you can still get adult flies that lack
centrioles
as was published a few years ago from
our lab
these adult flies without centrioles are
remarkably healthy
in all but one aspect and that is that
as they lack centrioles they also
lack cilia in their mechanocentric
organs
this means that they are uncoordinated
as you can see in this movie
they can't stand they can't fly they
can't feed themselves they have no
perception of the world around them
so this presents us with somewhat of a
problem if we want to study the eggs
from these females
as uncoordinated mutants don't tend to
lay many eggs
we overcame this problem by over
expressing using the uas gal4
system through
central duplication factor simply in the
canary sensory cells of the females
these females are otherwise mutant for
the
central assembly factor and therefore
they lay eggs
which totally lack the central protein
of interest
we can then assay whether saps can form
even in the absence
of the other core centriole proteins
one of the core central assembly factors
we were particularly interested in
was asthelus now as you can see from
this cartoon atlas has
somewhat of a dual role both in central
assembly
but also in pcm formation
as uh mutants in athelist don't have any
centrioles
it's very hard to assess the role of
athletes
in pcm assembly around the centrals
because they're no longer present
in uh a massless mutants
this is where the sap model came comes
in very
handy because as you can see from this
graph
about half of the embryos from an asylus
mutant
contain saps
compared to wild type the efficiency of
sat formation and astute's mutant is
decreased
but they're still present so excitingly
saps can form
even in the absence of atlas
this means we now have an assay where we
can assess the role of asylus in pcm
assembly
even in the absence of endogenous
centrioles
we also had a couple of tools we could
use these are two
asless mutants one asylus one
uh is a short truncation of atlas
where some truncated protein is still
produced
and this seems to act as a hypermorphos
where centrioles are present but pcm
formation is inhibited
the second mutant is a much stronger
mutant asylus mcd
this lacks centrioles and is completely
uncoordinated
but its role in pcm is somewhat unclear
we therefore express sussex and anatou
to form saps in both
the hypomorphic asylus one mutant
and an asylus null mutant and then
stained for the presence of spud2 and
cnn
for the presence of pcm components
as expected you can see in the graph
here
the percentage of saps in an atlas one
mutant
staining for cnn orthospa 2 was
basically
zero however unexpectedly
in the atlas null mutant the percentage
of saps
containing cnn and spud 2
was significantly above zero almost
fifty percent in the case of cnn
this suggests that the presence of the
truncated protein that's present in
anacelus
one mutant prevents pcm recruitment
and that in the total absence of
asterisks
um pcm can
actually form the question was how is
this
pcm recruited in the total absence of
atlas
to quickly address this issue we uh
expressed
sussex and anna ii to form saps in a
double
spa ii asterisk mutant
and then stained for the presence of
spud 2 or cnn
you can now see in this double mutant
cnn
is no longer present this suggests
that in the absence of athletes there is
an uh asylus independent backup pathway
for pcm formation
and that this backup path rate requires
spud 2
in order to recruit the pcm it seems
however that this backup pathway
appears to be much less efficient
compared to the main pcm recruitment
pathway which is asthelus dependent
so if we look at either spud2 or cnn
recruitment in wild-type saps
the intensities of these proteins
recruited is much greater
compared to the pcm recruited in the
absence
of atlas so if we look at our essential
assembly and pcm assembly pathway
this remains as was described with atlas
being
the main component for pcm assembly
formation
however in the absence of atlas there is
this second backup pathway
where something in the centriole is
required
to recruit the pcm via spud 2
in a much less efficient way so just to
summarize this quick
example of how we've used saps as a tool
to probe
central and centrosome proteins in the
absence of centrioles
saps form in the absence of atolus and
pcm can form around these saps
even in the total absence of athletes
this atlas independent pathway requires
spa
two but actually it's much less
efficient than the standard
asterisk dependent pathway for pcm
assembly
this work is part of uh part of a
publication that was just published
last month so if you want to read more
about the saps
i direct you to this paper in a journal
of cell science
so that just leaves me to thank you very
much for your attention
i'd also like to thank the raph lab in
particular jordan raff
but also cat percent and lisa garteman
for their work on the saps